and hamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be
with you thank you for tuning in to the
D show we have our next guest was going
to come out we interviewed him some time
ago he was with the US military he
accepted Islam several decades ago a
long time ago and we're gonna talk to
him some of the struggles that he's had
and has overcome we're gonna be talking
about a lot of the culture honor
killings that have been associated with
Islam arranged marriages and there's
many weird superstitions all of these
things that I'm sure many of the people
who come to Islam and even our living
Islam as Muslims they see that they're
practicing them where does a conflict
does it have anything to do with Islam
we're gonna learn all this and more with
our next guest when we come back here on
the Deen show
this is the assalamu alaikum violate
from salon what - turn up again
how are you remember al hamdulillah I
said you accept accepted of some decades
ago along pekus I don't know if it was
decades ago but it was a while ago it
was a while ago
how have you been since then
alhamdulillah people can go to the Deen
show calm to see your story I mentioned
that you were formerly in the military
US military yes since then now you're
actually a PhD candidate yes inshallah
I'm working on finish the masters of
education I'm working on a doctorate in
education in sha Allah give us for those
people who haven't seen your story just
kind of a a summary of your story from
what you talked about with this I was in
the US Navy for four years and I came to
his mom from basically disobedient
Muslims and so I used to hang out in the
nightclubs and where they used to drink
a lot of alcohol and I came into contact
with disobedient Muslims then this is
how I came into contact with Islam ended
up marrying a woman that was leaving the
path of Islam and doing a lot of the
disobedient stuff and she came to me one
day and asked me if I would marry her I
said no problem she said there's one
thing you have to become a Muslim I said
great what is that because I never knew
what a Muslim once was before so she
said all I have to do is go down and
repeat after the Imam and wham bam
Shazam I'm a Muslim the only thing is is
that thing's something changed I got in
contact with a the last and final
testament of Almighty God the Quran and
when I opened up that book and I started
to read it I realised there were certain
things in my life that I was doing that
I needed to change and so this led me on
my path to Islam and needless to say me
and the woman that I came into Islam
with we ended up parting ways she went
one way and I went a different way I
went down the path of knowledge and so I
started to learn more about myself in
the Creator
and what it meant to be one who submits
their will to the creator of the heavens
in the earth now what was it that you
had to say proclaim when you went down
to the mosque in front of the amount so
this is the testimony of faith that all
Muslims have to take in order to be a
Muslim and it's basically they call it
the Shahada tane which means two parts
of the testimony of faith so the first
part is la ilaha illaallah which means
that there is no god but God and the
second part is muhammad rasool ullah
which means Muhammad ibn Abdullah is his
slave and final messenger so he came
just like Jesus just like Moses just
like Jesus with the same message to
worship the one true God and to follow
their way because they're gonna show us
how to do it now if I remember correctly
from the interview you actually started
getting serious with Islam and the
actual the Muslims who you married she
wasn't correct there was more culture
involved wasn't it
right so she she was adapted to a lot of
the cultural things which had no basis
inside of Islamic teachings so the Quran
and the hadith which we pull our
traditions from the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and the Quran which we
pulled the traditions from Almighty God
there are many things in there that
Almighty God said about the certain
cultures even of the Arabs and it says
that these practices are very very not
good for society so go ahead and abandon
those practices and follow what the
messenger teaches you and so when you
look at that that's the whole picture of
what we have and so I submitted to
following the text of the Quran and of
the hadith which that ended up getting
rid of all of those cultural differences
yeah we see I mean that's why the show
is based on some of these cultural
confusions so you went through some of
those with the person in the beginning
can you name some of those things that
you went to well like for example you
know in that culture when they come came
to the United States and that it was
okay that a woman did not dress herself
in a proper way in a modest way it was
okay if for example during the rest of
the year if the men would go ahead and
drink alcohol go out and hang out their
clubs and that but during the month of
Ramadan they were in the
roads of the mosque Subhan Allah glory
be to God free is he from any
imperfection but these were cultural
practices that they saw that we're okay
to go ahead and do that they adapted
from other cultures also back in their
home country and that this was not
something that would be allowed even and
so it was just something that they
picked up from other cultures and and
this was a problem and so when I started
reading the teachings inside of the
Quran and inside of the hadith I saw
that there were many of these things
that were not allowed one of the biggest
things was drinking me being a
non-muslim before that I used to drink a
lot of alcohol I used to go out to the
clubs used to party used to do all of
these things and so I thought this was
normal but when I started seeing the
teachings inside of the book that it
says to go ahead and get rid of these
things and it went in a stages okay I
didn't just say abandon it it says in
these there are some goods but in these
there are some evils and so when I
started to look at this I was able to go
ahead and see hey what I'm doing right
now is not the correct thing so I need
to go ahead and remove this part of the
culture and even some of the cultural
baggages which I brought from the
culture that I learned in the American
culture I had to go ahead and remove all
of those because they conflicted with
the Islamic teachings and values which
were to go ahead and polish to train you
to teach you how to be a better person
now tell us you know that Islam makes
sense that's why you accepted it and
it's the fastest growing way of life in
the world Islam submission to the
Creator not the creation you know living
a good righteous wholesome life and when
you hear a lot of these absurdities on
the media like the honor killings forced
marriages what are you gonna say about
this right and even when the Quran was
revealed over a period of twenty three
years to the Arabs at the time and
particularly to the Quraish tribe which
was the tribe from which the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him he came from
this tribe
there were many cultural practices that
would they were doing that were based
off of ignorance that were based off of
what they call in the Arabic language
jahiliyyah which means ignorance and so
one of the things is they used to have a
lot of superstition and they used to say
that if they had a female daughter that
was born they would go ahead and bury
her alive now there is no legislation
from this at all they just followed
these superstitious acts and they acted
upon them and so I started to see this
not only in the American culture but
also around the world even in Islamic
cultures there were small little things
that actually violated certain concepts
of tawheed which means the oneness of
Almighty God and so these superstitions
these things in cultures sometimes go
against the teachings of Islam which is
pure and untarnished
whereas culture and that can have a lot
of problems and I tell a lot of my
Muslim brothers and sisters and that
it's okay to have culture it's okay to
have that identity but culture needs to
be sitting in the back seat not in the
front seat
okay Islam needs to be sitting in the
front seat that should be the driving
force and then culture should be
something that should go ahead and
enhance your Islamic morals and values
and teachings so honor killings so honor
killings now this is a very simple one
okay Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
the creator of the heavens and the earth
glory be to him he states in the Koran
that to take the life of one innocent
human being okay it's like you killed
all of humanity and to go ahead and save
one life is like you saved all of
humanity okay now we cannot carry the
burden of another person okay if one
person does a sin okay I can't go ahead
and take that burden from them and take
it okay just like some of the Christians
believe that Jesus died for their sins
and they took the burden of the sin as
human beings we can't do that we can't
bear anybody else's burden so to sit
there and say that I want to go ahead
and they're bringing shame upon my
family and I want to take their life
this is totally forbidden in the
teachings of Islam but to put this into
context even in the United States okay
this was a practice that was common
among US citizens and so if you go back
into the late 1800s in the 1900s you
would see this practice of honor
killings if somebody actually did
something that brought shame to the
family and then they would go ahead and
take the matter into their own hand and
since this was a patriarchal society
back in the 1800s the 1900s they didn't
get touched by the law and so this is
just something that is changing it's a
phenom
that gets exploited in the media a lot
especially in today's society all right
so we cleared a couple things up there's
there's no part-time Muslims kicking it
at the club and then coming and Ramadan
you know you're in it you're actually in
it to win it the whole year round so we
clear that up and then honor killings
absolutely not
not at all not allowed okay beautiful
we're gonna go ahead and take a break
and be right back with more with our
special guests
Jamal here on the Deen show his life
just about partying play and getting the
bling-bling
find out the purpose of life at the Dean
show calm don't forget to like us on
Facebook and follow us on Twitter please
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
tell all your friends and family about
the Dean show
back here on the Dean show and we are
discussing a very important topic
we have Islam which is simple clearly
under understand it's perfect Muslims
can be unperfect because there are human
beings so now a lot of the Muslims have
brought in many of these back home
cultures some are good actually some
give us some examples of some some good
things because obviously we don't
eradicate everything from the culture
but some things that would that you saw
it's on your studying that now someone
is probably doing and they've mixed it
in and they attribute this to Islam we
saw honor killings have nothing to do
with they give us another example so you
want a good example please ok so a good
example that Muslims actually taught me
that was something that used to be a
part of American values at one time was
the sense of family and community and
togetherness this is something that as
Americans and that that they can go
ahead and learn a lot from Muslims about
they're all about going ahead and living
together as a family eating together
taking time together taking care of the
whole entire family in fact this is an
act of worship an act of God and so this
is something that each and every Muslim
takes a lot of pride in and takes a lot
of work in doing so also when they are
elderly when they get older the the
children they go ahead and take care of
him there's no slowing them into a a old
folks home there's no putting them in a
nursing home I remember one time me and
my wife there she had a older lady that
she used to call grandma an American and
she was on her deathbed and she became a
Muslim it was the most amazing thing
that I ever saw but her children came
and we loved this woman very much so and
her children came and her son was even a
Catholic preacher and my wife was very
upset because of her Muslim morals and
values and how well we care about the
elderly they said listen it's been 12
days okay I need to get back to my life
I need to get back to my job can you
please just cut off the food cut off the
water
here's a woman in the last days of our
life and that and they want to go ahead
and put her through torture okay let her
die on her own terms but they wanted to
speed it up because of their attached
to the world and so she had a very hard
time with this and I didn't also I mean
cuz I cried for this lady that she had
to go through this but we are not her
children and so there was nothing that
we could do and so there are a lot of
good morals and values that come from
the culture that are actually based in
the roots of Islam and there are also
some things that come from the culture
and that that have no business being in
Islamic thing and that sometimes get
confused by Americans let's move to
another common one forced marriage can
you force someone to marry someone in
Islam actually in Islam this actually
there are some ayats in the Quran that
actually got rid of this whole forced
marriage thing and in fact in surah nisa
it says that you cannot make a woman
marry against her own world and also you
couldn't inherit women against their own
wealth which was a common practice among
the Arabs before Islam when a husband
would died they would go ahead and Herot
the whole entire household so they would
inherit the the the the wife they would
inherit the daughters they would inherit
all of that as property and so Islam
came to go ahead and give the rights to
the woman that they have a choice and to
say what they want now in the Middle
East for example in that they have a
difference of culture also to where men
and women they don't mix so it's not
like a free-standing dating Society
where you have men and women that are
mixing and so usually what would happen
is the parents would go ahead and find
them a spouse so if they had a son they
would find them a good woman they would
go talk to other families and that and
then arrange these marriages now doesn't
mean that they have to do this but what
it's saying is that the parents are
trying to provide them a platform that
they make something lawful so they don't
commit unlawful acts we know that Islam
I mean as I said early it's easy to
understand and usually you'll see that
some cultures now we gave some few
examples of the good things you have
some good foods all right send me
hospitality and then we have let's say
the dress you know
Islam there's a modest way of dressing
but some people have incorporated before
we go to break
now the thobe for instance that now
someone accepts Islam they have to wear
this stone what you have to say about
that one of the reasons why I'm wearing
this dress I prefer to actually wear the
thobe okay but if you actually look at
the Sunnah which is the way of the
Prophet peace be upon him he did not
wear the folk he wore what was called an
Islam which is more like a waste cloth
that goes down to here and a longer
shirt so he's more in line with what was
wore in modern-day Yemen there's a lot
of people in Yemen or maybe even some of
the older people in Somalia they wear
this sort of dress that was more towards
what he wore the thobe actually if you
look in American culture in that they
used to wear it in the 1800s and the
1900s here in America and they used to
wear it as pajamas so you can find
pictures of this F Americans wearing
this out in the Old West and stuff like
that and then also in the Middle East
and that they used to start off as a
pair of pajamas and then what ended up
happening is that designers started to
design it in different ways and they
started to wear it not just that night
time they wore it in the daytime so this
became a cultural thing now there's this
piece of cloth make them a Muslim no
it's a design it's a fashion it's a
cultural choice to go ahead and wear
something like that and there's nothing
in Islam that says that you have to
dress a certain way and that's the
beauty about Islam we have many
different people from many different
diversity 'z many different ethnicities
many different skin colors many
different races many different languages
and they all come together and they
worship one God the God that created all
of us we're gonna take a break coming
right back with more here on the Deen
show God says in the Quran what I
thought it was zero to mr. Loffler no
one is held accountable for what someone
else is doing so just because your
parents were going through what they
were going through it doesn't mean that
you're held accountable for what they
did nor will W had nor will they be held
accountable for what you
so you can't blame what you're doing on
your parents once you know better you
need the gym don't forget to like us on
Facebook and follow us on Twitter
please subscribe to our youtube channel
and tell all your friends and family
about the Deen show
back here on the Dean show with Imam
share you also are you an imam at a
mosque should you teach Islamic Studies
at are you an imam imam all Imam means
in the Arabic language is a leader so in
that aspect yes I I do a lot of
different teachings with about 900
students on the weekend we go through
the teachings of the Arabic language
looking at the linguistic cognitive
roots and so they can help understand
what the Arabic means that their
memorizing and then we also look at
Islamic history on the whole and our
Islamic Studies our foundation of why we
believe what we believe it's not like in
many of the other faiths on that that
there this by by birth like they were
born into the religion of Christianity
or they were born into the religion of
Judaism in Islam we are required to
actually seek knowledge and understand
why we believe what we believe we're
supposed to be working every single day
on our relationship with the creator of
the heavens and the earth and so a good
Muslim will always reflect on all of
this and keep on polishing and keep on
learning more as they go along on their
journey in life and so I I do a lot of
work with that but I also do a lot of
work with non-muslims I spend a lot of
my time going to church organizations
police fire department all of these
different organizations to go ahead and
teach them about what Islam is and what
Islam isn't unfortunately we got a lot
of bad publicity out there and so it
takes a lot of understanding and a lot
of teaching to get them through these
different things to help them understand
many of them they're very good people
and they want to understand who Muslims
are what are they for
what did they want okay are they like us
and so they're looking for a thing most
of them they have good intentions and so
we try to help them out in that aspect
well what was the the most important
thing that you felt that helped you to
be able to decipher culture so you can
see a clear okay this is Islam this is
what islam teaches and this is culture
so people out there who are stuck in
this trap they're kind of confused they
see it some weird things being
attributed to its line that's usually
the first thing if it's weird doesn't
make
it's way out there it's probably not
about a son because llama is the natural
way it makes sense and there's nothing
that the Creator told us to do that
something beyond our capacity and
something I just doesn't go with with
you know our human nature so tell us
what is this thing
I think the creator of the heavens in
the earth he gave us the best answer to
this question inside of the Quran he
says that when anybody brings you any
sort of piece of information to go ahead
and verify it and he gave us a formula
on how to verify it he said refer it
back to the Quran and the Sunnah of the
Prophet peace be upon him so if you find
it inside of the Quran okay then go
ahead and partake in it if you don't
find it in the Quran then you're going
to have to hold off for a second then
you need to go ahead and take the next
step and look into the traditions of the
Prophet peace be upon him and look for
the answers there now if you still do
not find what you're looking for there
it is not covered in that aspect
then you refer it to the scholars that
have given their understanding it's
called the jihad their understanding of
what the religion is and they have to
look for the burden of proof in there if
they still don't find it then you need
to stay as far away from that as
possible because then it is going to
take you into unlawful means and so it's
a very simple formula one of the
greatest things about Islam is that the
scholarship the way that it's done for
example if I want the Word of God okay I
go to the Quran if I want the word of
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him I
go to the Hadees if I want the word of
the Sahaba I go to another book if I
want the word of a scholar I go to
another book a historian another book
everything is separated out so it's easy
if I'm a been doing in the middle of the
desert with no formal education or I'm
an astrophysicist I can study on the
same level and know where the weight
lies but the people of the book they're
books you have the Word of God in there
you have the word the prophet in there
you have the word of other people in
there you have the word of historians
and it's all put in together into one
book and they say at the end of the day
that this is the Word of God they're not
being honest with himself because you
have the word of other thing so you
can't tell
is true and what is false and so we have
something that goes ahead and helps in
this scholarship and it's amazing the
scholarship of Islam and that's why so
many people can study Islam for their
whole entire life and they barely
scratched the surface of where the real
knowledge is now if someone says look if
I want to follow the Sunnah of the way
of the last and final messenger the same
way obviously if you were living during
the time of Jesus Moses Abraham you'd
have to follow their Sunnah their way
and the revelation I was given to them
by the Creator for guidance for mankind
so if someone says look if I'm gonna
follow this that I might as well might
as well be riding a camel you know how
do we get hip with the times then okay
very good so the Quran was not something
that was designed to be static that was
stuck back in seventh century Arabia
okay the Quran was designed for all of
humanity and in fact the creator of the
heavens and the earth he says today I
have perfected your religion for you he
didn't say today I perfected your
religion Muhammad he didn't say today I
perfected your religion at robes he said
all of mankind today this is the final
part to it I perfected it for you not
something that is supposed to sit there
trapped in time but something that
evolves as humanity is evolving along
with it okay so when you refer
everything back to the Quran and to the
Sunnah of the Prophet peace be upon him
you will find things in there that
actually relate into today's society so
for example if I take the scientific
miracles of the Quran that talk about
the three stages of darkness that human
embryology goes through or I can talk
about the water on how the barzakh or
the barrier that goes in between an
assault and the fresh water don't go
together or how hail is formed now this
wasn't something that Muhammad peace be
upon him and his companions were all
sitting around and looking up at the sky
and saying let's talk about science
today this is something that we as
modern human beings have derived the
meaning out of the text of the Quran and
it's the only book that I've ever come
across that it evolves with you as you
grow with it so the more that human
beings interact with it the more
knowledge that they pull outside of the
book and that is one of the signs of the
Creator that he created that book
so this is pretty simple I mean there's
the it's not static so no matter what
time if we're in 2014 what about 2020
even if you're in the year 3000 30,000
whatever the timeframe is it's gonna
adapt
it'll adapt because it was created by
the one who has knowledge of everything
and so he created it in the way that it
would go ahead and work with humanity as
it went along until that day which we
call the day of judgment when there will
be nothing else so we'd be able to
deduce that's what we call Fick from the
crown instan whatever needs to adapt to
any culture or society so anything
you'll have the tools to sit there and
go ahead and live in any environment
live in any place on the earth and be
able to survive and to thrive based on
the Quran and the Sunnah now this is
really amazing because obviously you
came from a background your parents
weren't Muslim that's correct
and now you were a former Christian
right great and you accepted Islam
submission to the creator not the
creation living a good wholesome life so
obviously you can get to paradise and
you know the same place where we hope to
meet Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
other messengers who are calling people
to a righteous good organic lifestyle
and obviously knowledge was so important
to get to where you're at to be able to
distinguish between culture and is
culture and Islam so what advice do you
have before we conclude for those who
are coming to Islam now and they're
facing these many challenges and they
are introduced to the culture mixed with
the religion some advice to our viewers
out there my biggest set of advice
actually I have two sets of advice one
to those who are new to Islam and will
one to those that are already Muslim the
first one to those that are just new to
Islam is to take it easy take it slowly
and learn knowledge from one who has
more knowledge than you always refer
everything back to the Quran and the
teachings of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him do not just accept things at
face value do not follow him blindly
and the last part to that is that take
the good parts from your culture which
you have with you and get rid of the bad
parts and this is something that is not
going to happen overnight something that
took me many many years to do and it's
gonna take them many years to wash out
all of that stuff that you learned that
was of no use the second piece of advice
is for the Muslims is to realize that
new people to Islam they need a lot of
help and they need a lot of guidance and
just because your cultural beliefs say
that you should dress a certain way
doesn't mean that they need to dress
that way they can be Muslim and have
their culture in that give them what
they need teach them from the Quran and
the Sunnah and teach them the beneficial
parts and you may even learn something
about your culture and stuff that may
not be that beneficial also that you may
think that maybe there is no basis for
this inside of the Quran and the Sunnah
of the Prophet peace be upon him and so
that's the two piece of advice I'd give
to the new Muslim and then also the
Muslims that have been Muslim for a
while it's beautiful to have you back
with us on the Deen show thank you for
helping us with your experiences and we
hope to in the next segment we're gonna
inshallah God willing open it up so the
audience can answer some questions for
those that are viewing us on the TV
inshallah God willing next week you can
join us for the open Q&A and until then
peace be with you Islamic